>> Okay. So we've done a little bit of moving,
moving stuff around, and kept the same equation of before. Remember,
our goal is to use quadratic programming to maximize this
equation. So let me talk a little bit about the properties
of the solution for this equation. So here's the first
one. It turns out that once you find the alphas that
maximize this equation, you can actually recover the W, which
was the whole point of this exercise in the first place
>> that's the little W,
not the big W
>> That's the little W, not the big W. That's right, okay?
>> Neat.
>> Yeah, that is kind of neat. So it's
really easy to do. And of course once you
know W it's easy to recover B. You just find the value of X, you stick it into
W, you, that you know is equal to plus 1, and then poof, you, you can find out
B. So you can recover W directly from this and you can recover B from it in sort
of the obvious way. But here are some other properties
that are a little bit, little bit more interesting for
you. So I want you to pay attention to two
things. One I am just going to have to tell
you, and the other I want you to think about.
So here's the one that I'm going to tell you.
It turns out, okay, that alpha, each of those
alphas are mostly zero, usually. So if I told you that in
the solution to this, most of the alphas that you come back
are going to be zero, what does that tell you about W?
>> So W is the sum of the data points times their labels
times alpha. And if the alpha is zero, that the corresponding data point
isn't really going to come into play in the definition of W at
all. So a bunch of the data just don't really factor into W.
>> That is exactly right. So basically,
some of the vectors matter for finding the solution to this, and
some do not. So it turns out, each of those points are
vectors. But you can find all of the support that you need
for finding the optimal W in just using a few of those vectors.
>> The non-zero alphas.
>> Yeah, well the ones with non-zero
alphas. So you basically built a machine that
only needs a few support vectors.
>> Oh. So the, the data points for which
the corresponding alpha is non-zero, those are the support vectors?
>> Yes, those are the ones that provide all the support
for W. So knowing that W is the sum over a
lot of these different data points, and their labels, and the
corresponding alphas, and that most of those are zeroes, that implies,
that only a few of the X's matter. Now Michael, let me let me do a quick quiz.
>> Yea, yea!